5 55 on your wednesday morning want to
clear up the rebuilding of a desert inn
bridge so you ask most drivers in las
vegas what is a desert inn bridge
they'll most likely come up with what's
officially known as that di super
arterial the one that takes desert in
over the i-15 under las vegas boulevard
in the center of alibaba that bridge not
going anywhere technically there is a
bridge that goes over d.i out on the
east side of town it is just south of
boulder highways interchange with a 95
515 it is this bridge that's getting a
makeover for now nevada department of
transportation laying the groundwork for
demolishing the bridge by making both
directions of the freeway one lane only
between midnight and 5 a.m until friday
morning also the off ramp to boulder
highway from the north freeway also shut
down during those overnight hours the
actual destruction of the bridge set for
next week and you know we'll keep you
posted on that buckle up drive carefully
and please put down that phone if there
is something driving you crazy email me
traffic 8 8newsnow.com